play with relentless physicality down  down our tradition is anything but  ordinary  our legends set the standards  Marcus Allen  it's a new year and our expectations are  immense  so let's go let's go  we are the mandatory  the Cardinal and go  and we will not back down  it's an investment built on hard work  and dedication for arrest  the endless two-a-days we don't get the  stock we don't get the pull-up we have  to spray the finish every play  constantly pushing never quit  one more inch one more rep  one more sprint  we are united  we are united  he's got a fight man I don't know  anything else to tell you what's a fight  we are here to battle  the wall of the Colosseum  V is for victory  the tradition  arrivals are in trend  we can't wait for the next chapter  here to win here to live here to win  here to win here to win  right on  you